you may not know the name CIO human but
I can guarantee you if you've seen more
than one poy video online you've
definitely seen someone who spins like
him sadil has arguably had the biggest
stylistic impact on the poy world since
Nick woy he remade POI in his own
radically different image so how did he
do it and what parts of the poy world do
we have to thank him for in this video
I'm going to tell you why I think Cil is
the father of modern po
[Music]
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and in this video I'm going to share
with you the many contributions of sadil
human to Modern poy and why he's one of
the few po spinners I'd argue can be
said to have started an entire stylistic
genre but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys pyroa
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the the non- buus
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission all right so first
up who exactly is seral human Cal human
is a French po spinner who has made
quite a splash over the course of the
past 15 years with a style that has
integrated a lot of dance circus contact
juggling and more and to understand why
seral was so influential it's helpful to
get an idea of what the pois scene was
actually like when he entered into it
for most of the early 2000s po had a
pretty limited vocabulary you had your
weaves butterflies and windmills but
except for a few outliers poy didn't get
much more complicated than that that is
until Nick wisey hit the scene Nick's
video dervish Le yours transformed the
PO scene and created many of the
conventions that we still use today it
oriented poy tricks on flat planes
relative to the audience and opened up
the world of poy flowers because of it
we started thinking of petrix in terms
of the shapes that they could create as
they spun a path through the air and if
you'd like to learn more about Nick and
the impact he had on the pois scene I
did a video on him that I'll link to
down in the description as well as up in
the Cards into this environment came the
first generation of tech po Spinners
people who took the idea of pattern
spinning and combining shapes and ran
with it Frameworks for understanding how
different poy tricks are related sprung
up practically overnight with the
emphasis always being how do we find the
next cool trick that nobody's performed
yet and it was in this environment that
s made his first major contribution to
the PO
world part one reflecting on the
past I first became aware of Cil when I
came across a Microsoft Word document
floating around on POI forums that was
called spinning and geometry and it was
a doozy sadil introduced a new Theory
and explanation for how he viewed timing
and direction from the standpoint of
symmetry as well as a lengthy Treatise
on how to explore a variety of different
simple geometric shapes with po this
spectac ularly detailed paper includes
not just pages and pages of different
patterns that seral had either already
performed or believed he could but also
included is what I think is the earliest
diagram I've found published of the
shape that we would come to call xan's
Diamond and as a reminder there is no
one in the world more baffled that this
trick came to be named after xan than
xan Moore himself lots of people got
there before him but what this paper
showed was that seral was already way
ahead of the curve and imag ining the
possibilities of Po and the shapes and
patterns that they could produce he saw
not just the potential for generating
complex patterns but also was openly
beginning to wonder what would happen if
we started to deconstruct our thinking
of how POI could move and be spun what
if we didn't think of the shapes we
create as being continuous what if we
paused and explored certain segments of
them with different driving Styles what
happens when you deliberately create
segments that overlap and interfere with
each other and what if you focused on
moving the handle instead of the head
sadil actually created a video to
explore these Concepts visually that he
called geometric firep it used what was
then kind of a difficult technique to
show off the trails of the poy and give
the viewer an idea of his theories in
action and unfortunately in what will
prove to be an ongoing theme it is also
sadly no longer accessible online but
trust me it was really cool looking so
did Cal's tretis become a foundational
work of the tech poy
World well it certainly had its admirers
myself included but by and large it
didn't quite make the same impact that
the work of people like alien JN and the
aforementioned Zan Moore did and that
wasn't for lack of good ideas believe me
but it did make it far more shocking
when Cil resurfaced with what I'd argue
was his most influential project still
to this
date part two three videos that changed
po 2010 was the year that Cil changed
the PO world forever he did this by
dropping a video called Mana poy that
like dervish Le yours is one of those
moments when you can see the entire poy
World hinge on a single video contact
poy had existed for years prior to that
Ronin had invented them some time before
and even carved out some basic contact
poy vocabulary with them but rare was
the person who actually learned these
tricks or even picked up a set of these
poy in the somewhat unusual
circumstances that somebody would
actually pick up contact poy it was
almost never to learn learn how to do
contact roles with them overwhelmingly
it was because they made stalls and
pendulums look awesome in fact they were
originally marketed not as contact poy
but as pendulum poy when home of poy
sold the first commercial sets so it's
not an understatement to say that going
from working on intricate poy patterns
like what would become known as xan
Diamond to working on contact poy was
shall we say unconventional but my
goodness did it have an impact
unfortunately like geometric POI Mana
poy has been unavailable to view now for
several years leaving this a very
crucial piece of Po history lost to the
ravages of time but I can tell you
several things that did appear in it
sadil had been deeply studying the art
of contact juggling and was able to
truly fuse together many of its most
popular tricks into things that he could
perform with POI among the highlights
were folding lines transfers isolations
and stalls all performed with poy for
the first time on video and almost
overnight everyone had to learn how to
do contact poy Ronin may have invented
contact poy but for the generation that
transitioned from Techo to manipulation
between 2010 and 2013 it was Cal's heels
that they were biting at his vocabulary
they sought to duplicate his Innovations
they wanted to measure up to I actually
think it's fair to say that without
sural contact poy would not have become
fashionable let alone the default form
factor and style of the poy world today
now this is not to say that they're
having haven't been other innovators
working in the same style who also
Advanced the art forward Keith
Marshall's work was also incredibly
important not just for innovating
further upon the style but also for
physically touring the United States in
the early 2010s and teaching people the
concepts face to face Tim Goddard also
worked to popularize the style not just
by creating his own tricks but also by
creating tutorials that explained how to
do many of the wild Explorations that
seral was showing off and there are
countless others too but is there a
timeline in which contact poy takes over
the poy world as it did without Mana poy
coming out I honestly don't think so few
people cared much about contact poy
before it was released and everybody
cared about it after and as it turned
out Cil was just getting warmed up his
next major work melting poy was released
the following year and while it also
included many elements of contact poy to
it he expanded greatly on his
experimentation to include a dizzying
array of body tracers throws and even a
shocking amount of dance elements thrown
in as well but more than that it was
clear that Cil had radically reimagined
the poy as an object it wasn't just
purely a prop used to draw out patterns
anymore it was a thing to be balanced a
thing to get tangled in and perhaps most
importantly it was a thing to be thrown
this video includes a dizzying array of
what would eventually come to be known
as no beat throws where in POI are
thrown with the characteristics of a
flat or penguin throw in juggling the
idea being that rather than spinning the
POI as it tumbles overhead that one
should control the momentum of it to
create throws in which the performers
Mastery of the Poise momentum is as
clear in the air as it is when they're
holding it and it also includes an
enormous amount of throws performed
across the body in various permutations
from side to side or front to back all
the above and everything in between
there additional sections on Tangles
isolations and negative space this video
covers an obs absurd amount of ground
and it Remains the most viewed video on
cil's YouTube channel and yes it was
indeed followed up another year later
with another grand breaking video this
one called brainstorming and dude this
one goes hard on the throws and I do
mean hard unlike the leisurely editing
of melting poy brainstorming seemed
edited for the Tik Tok generation at all
times there is something new being shown
it is a Non-Stop barrage of intense and
virtuosic throws contact and negative
space work it also features some of
Cal's most physically demanding work
leaps leg traps pettes of Plenty and
much more where before sural seemed
content to throw out an idea or two and
let them stand on their own he's now
exploring momentum seeing how far he can
continue the Poise movement to create
phrases that have a distinct beginning
middle and end now you may have noticed
that we are now quite far off the road
map we originally started on we're no
longer spinning flowers like Nick woy or
even performing diamond and yes I would
argue that Cal's work represents the
critical transition point from the older
Tech poy movement to a newer one that I
like to
call part three the road to
manipulation this is a somewhat
controversial position but as I've
outlined in other video essays I believe
that there was a clear stylistic break
from the tech po movement of the late
2000s to the current dominant style
which I refer to as manipulation in the
early 2010 where Tech Poise centers
around performing patterns while the
Poise kept spinning and creating
Frameworks of thought to understand how
many of these patterns interrelate
manipulation sees the POI more as a
found object and integrates techniques
such as contact juggling toss juggling
and negative space into its use of the
prop and those three pillars contact
juggling toss juggling and negative
space are all aspects of Po that Cal not
only explored but popularized and again
there's no shortage of other po Spinners
to point to who've done influential work
in this realm as well but I believe it's
seral that is the true Lynch pin here
the Maestro from whose Symphony all the
other artists were playing nowadays if
you watch more than a couple poy videos
on any given platform you will find
someone making extensive use of one or
more of these techniques contact POI and
tosses have become as much a part of the
vocabulary of poi as weaves and flowers
before them Cil was one of the many
influences working to bridge the gaps
between the POI and circus or juggling
world and I would argue he's been one of
the most successful to do it as well
finding a role in the visual juggling
project and on stages of juggling
conventions I don't think that it's a
stretch to say that few people in the
POI world even knew what contact poy was
before manip poy was released and
afterwards few people wanted to be left
behind as it became clear that it was
the wave of the future the modern
emphasis on virtuosic throws is doing
huge part to his influence the ever
broadening array of contact poy tricks
out there are expansions of the
vocabulary he defined I don't think that
it's any coincidence that in 2012 the
first year that I hosted the top 10
favorite po Spinners list here on my
channel seril was the guy who topped the
list it was one of those rare moments
where even at the time the long-term
influence of a person's work is
immediately obvious we have been living
in the era of manipulation now for more
than 10 years in the PO world and I
honestly think the Catalyst for creating
that world was the work of Cil human if
you're rolling a poy head across your
body or tossing it in creative ways
you're either working directly in his
mold or in the mold of somebody who was
cribbing notes from him and that's
pretty impressive if you ask me thanks
for the groundbreaking World Cal we are
living in a world that you helped bring
into being so you may have noticed that
this video focused heavily on Cal's
Place in the history of poi and his
impact on the POI Community while saying
comparatively little about what defines
his style or why it shifted so radically
between his geometry paper and manao and
that's because I've put together a video
essay on those topics over on my second
Channel this is a channel I've created
to explore po work from a more artistic
perspective and that seemed like a great
place to put those thoughts you can go
check it out to get my thoughts on what
I believe seril has been trying to
achieve in his work what most of his
followers either miss or disregard when
they copy from him and why I think his
and my work actually have some
surprisingly similar intentions behind
them but for one key difference that
video is live now over on my other
channel at poy dancer Drex Link in the
description has Cil had a major
influence on your spinning what tricks
have you picked up from him leave me a
comment and let me know also be sure to
like share and subscribe to keep the
conversation going and to help my
channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
making this Channel and the videos on it
possible and if you enjoyed this or any
other video on my channel and you would
like to support my work please check out
my patreon over at patreon / drexfactor
poo and sign up you can get access to a
whole host of amazing rewards but even
better than that you'll be supporting me
in my mission to bring po spinning and
flow Arts to the whole wide world go
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like to learn more about a
person that I think is one of the great
unsung innovators of the Techo
generation I did a whole video essay on
why we do not give Leo aaza nearly
enough credit for his contributions to
the poy world and why that needs to
change you can find the link to it up on
screen here thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace